fantastic to be here packed audience
didn't expect this when Roger Federer is
probably out on court right now in the
Wimbledon men's finals when I was
creating this talk I was thinking let's
make it something contextual let's talk
about something slightly different and
it's just after lunch on the final day
the conference
wanted to check that you're still pumped
up with excitement so hype to stimulate
to excite to promote or publicize hype
it's an interesting thing isn't it like
we're all at the center of it at the
moment is data scientists pie data
there's a huge amount of papers being
published every week at archive
industries celebrating at such a rapid
pace this is a lot of hype going on at
the moment around data science the
industry and then there's also the hype
cycle so I planned a really a theatrical
talk to kind of fit in with this theme
of the hype cycle but unfortunately Alec
from Silicon Valley stole my lighting
setup to present Pied Piper but the good
news is at least there's not that many
spotlights on me today so if something
goes wrong like it did with with her
like maybe you won't notice so what is
the hype cycle well it consists of proof
mr. Porter P Diddy DJ Khaled
so so proof and the mr. Porter were in
our height men for Eminem notorious well
P Diddy was a hype man for notorious
b.i.g as I'm sure you're all familiar
with and dj khaled well did I say DJ
khaled is high man for dj khaled he's
the best right so we can expand this as
well so Eminem collaborated with Rihanna
actually the hope cycle is not about all
of that but you may have noticed in that
process we've ended up connecting all of
this data together and that does come
back to the theme of the talk so
actually the hype cycle is a report by
Gartner a global research and advisory
firm and emerging technologies so it
comes back this point emerging
technologies require revolutionizing the
enabling foundations that provide the
volume of data needed for and advance
compute power and the ubiquity enabled
ecosystems the shift from siloed
technical infrastructure to ecosystem
enabled platforms is laying the
foundations for completely new business
models and forming the bridge between
the humans and technology so Gartner
have recognized that knowledge graphs
just like this one well maybe not so
much this one are key to key technology
to enable this trend I've always
pictured myself as a bit of a
fashionista
[Music]
my lifelong fascination with the fashion
and the machine learning led me to
become lead data scientist at the far
fetch so at far fetch I'm pursuing my
vision of reimagining Vito to create a
smart and personalized shopping
experience I focus on the intersection
of machine learning and knowledge
representation so things like knowledge
class to build novel solutions that can
improve the customer search and browsing
experience so as the following on quite
nicely from the following talk so now
I'm in the team named inspiration data
science so where would this talk be
without me attempting to inspire you
beyond the hype men and hype woman so as
you can see I've I have used
state-of-the-art cutting-edge photoshop
skills to copy and paste of these images
are from our website into this a
presentation so this is a stunning PI
data themed outfitted into this you can
buy each element from our website
there's even a 101 item is a two-in-one
item
so the snake the snake soft toy can be
used both as a soft toy and accessory
and also as a scarf also we have Robert
Cavalli
snake print t-shirt and just a Cavelli
snake buckle belt and if you're not so
into the t-shirts then there's also the
fantastic Gucci jewelry so we have the
snake ring pendant necklace and also the
snake Gucci garden snake inspired ring
which would look absolutely fantastic
when you're typing and sure to attract
all the latest the talent your team's
so what is far fetch four fetch exists
for the love of fashion we believe in
empowering individual individuality and
our mission is to be the global
technology platform for luxury fashion
connecting creators curators and
consumers we operate modular end-to-end
technology platform purpose-built to
connect the luxury fashion ecosystem
worldwide and the only truly global
luxury digital marketplace at scale
where lovers of fashion any way in the
world can shop for unrivaled range of
incredible products just like I was
shown from the world's best brands and
boutiques so as you can see in the year
2018 1.8 1.4 billion
Greece merchandise merchandise value and
with all the with all these expectations
on the luxury fashion comes a lot of
challenges to in the data science to use
the technologies and also expertise
within the company to form concrete and
the authority of fashion taxonomy and
attributes for the entire consumer
experience PS we're hiring so what is
this graph thing what is knowledge graph
you might say hey I've got this lit bar
graph visualization for you it's fire
well that's not correct that's not where
this talk is about so that's great no
one left so you're here for knowledge
graphs and not bar graphs says good
start so why we all here today
so we're taking a new perspective on
data emphasizing relationships so we're
all here to connect PI data provides a
forum for us all to connect with each
other connect to connect knowledge
sharing ideas insights and of course
where would it be with our so sharing
new bleak curated fashion python themed
outfits we're in a rapidly advancing
industry where would we be without hype
where would we be without connections
where would archive be without archive
sanity where would your research paper
or your blog place be without hyping it
up on Twitter or waiver or whatever
social network it might be so businesses
and their products and services
what about entities and relationships
and often the screen you can see a
couple of examples of entities and
relationships in industry so for example
at far fetch consumer searches a product
with terms you might across an eBay here
today where the driver provided a trip
to you the rider and you may have a
Facebook account where you share your
status with friends so the world we live
in is all about these entities and
relationships and connecting these so
how can we represent analyze and
visualize this kind of data what is the
knowledge graph how many of you so how
many of you have heard of knowledge
graphs before I've seen there's a few
and how many of you have heard of graph
database before roughly two-thirds so
for those of you who are not familiar
with the knowledge graphs and the graph
databases let's kick this off with a
high-level explanation of what a graph
is and then we'll take a deeper dive
into the use cases and more specifically
application to fashion and the luxury
retail giving you a glimpse into how we
are building and evolving in a fashion
knowledge graph we're too far fetch so
in its essence a graph is an abstract
data type that requires two building
blocks nodes or entities and
relationships so knowledge graph can
describe a collection of nodes or
entities in our case
Farfetch'd representing business and
fashion entities where each node has
content contains information referred to
as properties so in this case the
properties could be something like
product ID or language so we have
numerous language sites so we may have
language of English or language of
Chinese or so forth so we can capture
that all in the graph and then each we
have these labelled relationships as
well between nodes so not only do we
have the relationship itself but we can
also label them and attach properties to
these relationships so in this example
we have a d ng d ng type bag which is a
product has some properties on it has a
term which is a leopard print and that
leopard print inherits from another
attribute animal print and then there's
also a synonym which is another
attribute of leopard sports
so we're connecting all this so data
it's all starting to get very semantic
so at the end of it we have knowledge
represented by a huge set of dots and
lines dots and lines from top to bottom
from side to side and trust me it's very
challenging to persuade a business
especially one in the luxury fashion
industry to support a technology which
has visually visually clashing sense of
style dots and lines don't always work
too well together
so in many ways there's a simple way of
modeling data what tends to be appealing
which which tends to be appealing to us
as we often want to simpler things
especially in business where we need to
maintain things and evolve things over
time so it's a very powerful but very
powerful especially when the data is
naturally very connected with a
meaningful relationships as we'll
discover in a minute graphs are
everywhere they're all around us many of
them we can't we come across all the
time on a daily basis so one of my
favorite ways to explain a graph is by
looking at all this connected data which
surrounds us so one example is the
London tube network we have a bunch of
stations as nodes and then we have the
connections the relationships between
those stations so how can I travel from
PI data to get a bite to eat and say
Soho or if this talk goes badly maybe a
drink in Soho well that would be an
indirect path in this graph we could
apply a graph theory such as a shortest
path algorithm to calculate the shortest
distance but more interestingly we we'd
want to ideally achieve a more valuable
insight so we can apply weights and
properties along those to those
connections and nodes in the graph and
then apply more complex graph analysis
or graph based AI to really deliver
valuable insights which is what I'll
head on to next so how many of you have
how many of you remember the Panama
papers so quite a lot so yeah this was
one of the biggest stories in 2016
prior to the other fantastic stories of
the year Donald Trump and being elected
and also brightened so it started the
Panama Panama papers started with a to
journalist
newspaper who were contacted by an
anonymous source who basically said yo I
have a lot of data from a law firm that
specializes in offshore tax accounts or
something along those lines
so offshore tax accounts those in the
tax friendly jurisdictions can be used
broadly for two purposes one legal tax
planning and the two illegal tax evasion
so the source contacted the journalist
and she said I'm a massive data leak of
all the internal documents of this a law
firm offshore law firm do you want to
have a look the journalist happens to
say yes and run this or this data says
2.6 terabytes of data they ran this
through a massive pipeline of algorithms
and ended up with 11.5 million documents
they wanted to discover are there any
interesting really interesting stories
in this data that are worth publishing
in the papers so investigative
journalism is all about patterns looking
at how things are connected not so much
directly connected as that's often
obvious people already often know about
the obvious direct connections in a
graph so the focus that we're usually
interested in especially in a case such
as investigative journalism is on
focusing on the in directed sorry
indirectly connected stuff so here's an
example of such a pattern so we have a
pretty typical pattern of a person who
has a bank account with just a normal
Bank UK bank u.s. bank whatever it may
be and then that person that person
lives at an address so one two three
Street whatever and then this other
person B happens to also live at the
same address
and that person is an officer of company
X and where is company X registered it
happens to be registered
without Bahamas bank so we have nodes
and relationships along with the
attributes and with that we can model
everything so given an infrastructure
with data of this form whether it be 100
connections or billion connections at
that point you can derive really
valuable insights and a completely new
perspective on data how powerful our
knowledge graphs well the prime minister
of Iceland at the time of at the time of
this Panama papers kicked off he ended
up having to leave his job as he hadn't
disclosed that he had this account in an
offshore tax haven so graphs can be
pretty powerful and by analyzing all
these indirect relationships
particularly so the organization behind
it the IC
IJ ended up winning the Pulitzer Prize
from this as well so how can we do
something similar in our own domain
whether it be retail whether it be
finance for example or something else
how can we find the powers amongst our
data well if you want to pull without
analyzing all the deep indirect
connections yourself may I suggest the
Delfina Doretta is a trillion earring
alternatively if you're more of a
diamond person we can rephrase the
question as how can we discover the
diamond in this data well in that case
you might be interested in the Jimmy
Choo diamond sneakers available from
far-fetched
so out far fetch we're building up this
knowledge graph on luxury fashion
products so in business and generally
with knowledge graphs we have this a
question of generic versus
domain-specific knowledge graphs so
generic can include all all of the
various entities within the business
such as a customer's orders payments
promotions reviews and the fashion
specific domain can include two things
like colors entities for colors entities
for materials
concepts trends all the all of these
wonderful things and then of course
there's mobile app as well so we have
products brands categories all these
kind of things which form an overlap
between generic and the main specific
knowledge crafts in this case so how
about file fetch how we building this up
and what are the some example use cases
so we have a free text search where
we're so free text search is all about
increasing and product discovery so in
terms of fat in the context of fashion
it could be using a synonyms and the
rich attributes to increase discovery
for our consumers searching products so
searching a skiing or winter sports or
things like this so synonyms as an
example there's also semantic search so
semantic search is responsible for query
understanding seeking to improve the
search accuracy by understand their
consumers intent and the contextual
meaning of terms to generate more
relevant results we also have some
example use case like recommendations so
how do we increase the relevance of
based on a richer product attributes and
giving these deep connections within a
graph and then also we have a number of
other example use cases such as ranking
so given a product list page for example
on any camera
site how can we improve the ranking of
results on that that list page so how we
building the fashion knowledge a fashion
knowledge graph
well the fashion knowledge graph tackles
the incredibly complex task of
associating every product with a
concrete and abstract fashion concepts
it allows the shoppers to search for the
best products that fit their needs like
tops for Glastonbury or maybe a snake
snake print street wear for example so
it will kicks off with a knowledge
collection so we have a bunch of fashion
experts who can help provide expert
knowledge in the fashion domain and then
of course we also have a data-driven
insights so this is all about using data
science and analytics to analyze things
like a search queries and also use AI
and modeling to extract as much value as
we can in order to collect knowledge to
build the graph appointment and then we
have this a second layer of taxonomy and
the graph construction this where we're
performing more modeling and knowledge
cleaning the fun part and also things
like entity resolution and schema
mapping so actually looking more at the
semantics of these and these entities
and building up basically converting
attributes into these semantic entities
and then ingesting them into this graph
so we end up with this a graph which
associates fat in this case fashion
taxonomy entities with the business
entities and then there's a whole bunch
of potential applications such as those
we just discussed so a universal fashion
taxonomy
within the graph understands the new and
nuanced and complex relationships
between fashion and the fashion lover so
for example when Klee things can be
included such as materials colors trends
concepts and concepts can also include a
range seda torial emotive seasonal so in
the fashion industry seasonal seasons
are big thing and to provide an example
we can have a product one where we have
this festival say which is a concept and
the festival we happens to be a
Glastonbury in this case so we have a
product one which is has a connection
with the Glastonbury and also connection
with the summer and of course also a
connection with the snake Prince then we
have a second example so in this case
exploring materials so as you can see we
we can capture quite detailed semantics
in the graph such as not only is this a
denim but we know that denim is a child
of cotton which is a child of textile
which is a child of materials so we have
that context we have those semantics and
we have all of these connections
building up such as variety is acne
brand and we know acne is a Swedish
feature Swedish design and then we can
have a more descriptive attributes as
well such as is this a product a skinny
fit or regular fit or these kind of
things and as well colors so not only
the standard colours you might see on
the filters on a website but also more
diverse in granular colors which enable
consumer to search for that term and
discover those products
to provide an example of synonym
enrichment we can take a look at this a
puffer jacket so we can enable users to
consumers to discover this item whether
or not they saw it specifically for
puffer jacket so they they could search
a quilted jacket or down kite or Devo
jacket or any of these things and this
graph will help consumers to discover
not only discover products but also
discover much more relevant products by
these connections deep connections with
rich and granular attributes so I bet
you're thinking what are some of the
techniques that were using for this this
kind of solution so we're using a
combination of computer vision deep
learning NLP conflation handling merging
of attributes and inference so this is
the best best emoji I can find to
describe inference but essentially a
given one given one products how can we
infer what what other products have
relations with that and such as which
other products may have a similar
patterns similar colors and all of these
good things and then the finally
crowdsourcing or human-in-the-loop type
approach to helping sure we get that
text but incorporate that expert opinion
as well so at the end of the day we have
a richer product data by using this
graph so we performing by for internal
enrichment and we can perform as well
external enrichment by things like
scraping and all this kind of stuff to
build up a context of these products in
the cart in the catalog so we we start
with the existing catalog data and then
we apply AI and modeling on this data
and
it's the top of the pyramids we have a
graph that connects all of these as rich
and semantic entities so we're turning
this this is sparse text data into
action into a rich collection of things
so this is one of the big
differentiators where is going from text
to text to strings to things so we have
we're catching all these semantics so
building a graph in the Python can be
relatively simple so there's a great
library called Network X which many of
you may be familiar with and we can
declare a directional graph so that's
one with arrows by just saying an X in
this case i graph and then there's some
simple commands to add nodes to that
graph or add edges and those nodes and
edges can also feature properties in
this case a name such as a product a or
a weight such as 0.75 and weights come
in very handy for more advanced analysis
and their graph based AI so given that
code we can so graph databases queries
written against graph databases are
closer to how the data is modeled than
other query languages great advantage of
the graph databases that you luminate
the need to join multiple tables to find
those relationships between your data
points because the relationships are
embedded in the data themselves so some
of the top paragraph databases are where
some of the main ones are neo4j which
has these Python packages for it and
there's also AWS Neptune and
and as your cosmos and a number of other
great graph databases one of the big
advantages perhaps with neo4j is it's
not tied into any one particular cloud
platform so it's a more portable
solution although that does require
perhaps more setup and management than
some of the built in solutions into
cloud platforms so what better way to
demo the fashion-based knowledge graphs
than your fav game fortnight number one
game in the world
I'm sure you're all fans so after the
conference so I played a little example
where on my github G cushion so a quick
example say if we want to show nodes in
the graph we can perform a simple query
like this as you can see is quite
similar to a sequel so this is showing
all the outfits in available well a
subset of the outfits available in the
fortnight game by Epic Games we may want
to say find just display all of the
outfits we can see them without the
connections and then as well we can
explore more interesting tasks such as
find so Ninja is a big for Knight player
how can I find which outfits we both
like so with the ninja and George as
names matching user likes outfit where
the name is in names and then return
these relationships so in this case so
we discover that both ninja and me
as a quick aside you probably discovered
that it's not always a frictionless
process to manage two different projects
so I just so I give a quick shout out to
a PI M and F M it's a fantastic tool for
your project and also it gives me an
opportunity to include the mandatory
xkcd diagram which seems like all the
data science presentations must have so
one thing you may be interested in is
how to communicate a graph in the
enterprise and so project managers will
often ask how can we improve their
customer experience how much how much
money can we make from this data
scientists might say wow looks like a
newer Network hold my pandas I'm a vote
backend engineers might say why do we
need a graph which graph database meets
the requirements and data engineers
might say is your airflow dizzy its
traversing through cyclic connections
where do I see most value Mountain value
with the knowledge graph well improving
customer experience such as by
understanding customer intent and search
queries this big one and connecting
further business entities within a
business for hyper hyper personalization
I also believe it's a big one as well as
a deriving new knowledge by graph
analysis and graph base AI and enabling
new innovative applications by taking
this new perspective on data especially
if it's naturally highly connected data
so research I just talked very briefly
about this so machine learning is all
about analyzing data to learn a model
and using an algorithm that can be
applied to make predictions on new data
sets machine learning is not tied to a
particular represent representation of
data machine learning algorithms help us
to discover meaning in the data sets and
insights can be expressed as
relationships between nodes in the graph
so graph databases enable efficient
storage and Traverse traversal of
information about relationships
therefore a graph therefore graph data
can be either
input or output as part of a machine
learning process and the graph
embeddings of one of the heavily
researched concepts at the moment in the
fields of graph based learning
I won't say too much on that as running
out of time
I will summarize as why use a knowledge
graph so if you have highly connected
they naturally highly connected data and
it can make it may make a lot of sense
for your project especially if you want
to derive new insights from a graph
analysis and their graph based AI and
enable stakeholders to easily visualize
relationships as well in order to make
informed decisions and as a flexible
schema to facilitate evolution as you
may wish to evolve the graph over time
adding more business entities into it
and is thought to my highly optimized
for storing and querying graphs so
relationships are fundamental structure
in the graphs so following relationships
in the graph is a single lookup so this
is a really really big thing so it makes
the operation blazingly fast compared to
traditional sequel database the future
so almost finished over 75% of for
whatching 100 have used a graph database
either adopted or piloted it and expect
that within the next three years that
figure will reach 100 percent it's a
natural fit their graphs ideal for
storing connecting and making inferences
from a complex data the feature of data
science and analytics so lies in
connecting data semantics and deriving
new insights from deep indirect
relationships not only about the more
obvious direct relationships graph
neural networks will play an important
role in a eyes development and the main
reason that graphs have not played an
important role in ml so far is that
legacy graph databases cannot deliver
what is really needed for machine
learning deep link graph and analytics
for large data sets so it's only
recently that companies can use graphs
at true scale
and by integrating graphs with a deep
learning we're moving much more into a
core understanding of artificial
intelligence deep neural networks and
image recognition I firmly believe that
is the intersection of a deep learning
and a knowledge representation with the
graph technology where the next
evolution lies and where new disruptive
companies are merging so there's a
little bonus here if you want to go on
it afterwards there's a tool I developed
to create professional websites from
markdown jupiter-mass studio it's
available on my github 4G cushion so
there's powering 100,000 websites and
featured in github spoke recently is a
greater view and academic publishing
papers or giving talks or all these kind
of things that's designed specifically
for creating markdown content for talks
papers publications slides all of these
things
[Applause]
yes this is so the embedding parts is
still is a part that we're researching
at the moment says working in progress
essentially so is a bit early for us to
say exactly so how many nodes and
relationships that we have in the graph
so we're capturing all of the products
in a catalog and then a bunch of
taxonomy fashion taxonomy nodes
associated with them so it's a million
plus I can't provide the exact number
but over a million nodes and
significantly more relationships sorry
which language
Seifer is the most by far the most
popular way to query a graph database as
developed by neo4j which is the primary
[Applause]